ich fand sehr interessant auch als
julian dazu gesagt hat denn da kommen ja
ein bisschen zu meinen aber ich habe
immer gedacht jetzt in den vergangenen
zwei jahren schlimmer als jetzt geht es
ja gar nicht mehr so ist habe ich
wahnsinnig auf den vergangenen zwei
jahren gedacht dann kam der krieg und es
geht eben doch schlichen wie schlimmer
dann hat mich auch sie liebe zuschauer
fangen wir denken sie gerade über grone
spielt es für sie noch irgendwie eine
große rolle bei all den herzzerreißenden
bildern die wir jeden teil aus der
ukraine sehen und genau ich jetzt kommt
dann auch heute die nachricht die masken
pflicht der gebiete jetzt angesprochen
diese in den schulen die soll fallen und
dann freue ich mich endlich mal eine
gute nachricht aber moment die betonung
liegt hier wieder auf soll mich auf wird
dann werden sie befolgt fahren wir in
deutschland weiter eine runde auf dem
panini kubicki ich weiß nächste woche
gesetzt da kommen wir auch gleich zu
aber dennoch eine die situation gerade
hamburg macht sich mit die kinder dürfen
musikunterricht die maske abnehmen wenn
sie in die gleiche richtung singen und
in bayern müssen die kinder zunächst mal
die maske weiter tragen ausser im
sportunterricht und dann gibt es immer
noch eltern weiterhin auf zero wird
wochen und vor einer durchseuchung übern
und ich sage ihnen ganz ehrlich ich will
auch nicht dass meine kinder corona
bekommen aber ich habe diese woche wird
acht so können wir auch nicht
weitermachen ist wenn es eben doch noch
schlimmer kommt als wir alle dachten
dann hilft nur noch eins menschlichkeit
und aufeinander achtgeben besonders auf
unsere kinder acht geben und sie müssen
einfach jetzt in jedem bundesland frei
werden von der maske in der schule ich
weiß herr kubicki ich gebe ihnen gleich
das wort das wird kommen nächste woche
aber nach all dem was wir in zwei jahren
erlebt haben in brisante nie erlauben
sie mir eine gewisse
restzweifel daran ist dass auch in der
nächsten woche und dann auch in allen
bundesländern passiert wird denn es
scheint mir so dass wieder jedes
bundesland sein eigenes süppchen
irgendwo kochen wird und es kleine wege
geben wird wie man doch drum herum kommt
aber sie haben das wort wenn sie mir
versprechen können dann im april ist die
masken freiheit in den schulen darf ich
glaube es ihnen gern ich versteh ich
verspreche ihnen dass sie in dem neuen
text schutzgesetz ist keine regelung zu
finden dies will ende mai gibt masken
pflicht anzuordnen den schulen und das
wird steht es am zweiten april und am
dritten april überall bundesweit der
fall sein dass die massen warum weil die
länder noch zwei wochen lang eine
übergangsvorschrift in anspruch nehmen
können damit es keine regelungslücke
gibt führen wirkens hatte und deren
jetzt die gefahr auch wenn dürfen bis
zum zweiten training bleibt aber
spätestens am zweiten april am dritten
april kann ich versprechen die masken
sich deutschlandweit an allen schulen
und wurzeln und dennoch muss ich ihnen
sagen es soll sich dann ja ist mit der
jetzt schon nach selten kleinen
feinheiten gesucht um sich auch auf den
winter vorzubereiten da will man sich ja
nicht mehr anschwellen werten
orientieren weil wir haben jetzt gelernt
neu von karl lauterbach das bringt ihr
überhaupt gar nichts schwellenwerte also
das was uns zwei jahre lang durch die
pandemie getragen hat mit instanzen und
so weiter das ist jetzt quatsch das
bringt gar nichts mehr deswegen möchte
man nur noch auf sogenannte hotspots
schauen und auch schauen ob es
gefährliche varianten gibt oder ob eben
in den krankenhäusern ein problem
auftritt und genau da denke ich wird es
dann eben wieder natürlich nicht zu
flächendeckenden schulschließungen und
flächendeckenden masken pflegt eine
schulen kommen herr fleischhauer aber
natürlich auch wieder gebietsweise oder
bin ich sehr zu pessimistisch ich lasse
mich gerne wieder
ja also bei kind geht in bayern der
schule bislang wieder strenge masken
pflicht jetzt hat unser
ministerpräsident der ja immer auch ein
bisschen nicht nase im wind hat schon
vorher angekündigt die woche war im
sportunterricht schon freigabe und
nächste woche dann insgesamt in den
schulen also die maske insgesamt nur
sagen dass so
dass wir das überhaupt so hingenommen
haben
ich hab mich neulich bitten damit kinder
erste unterhalten das hat natürlich
schon gravierende auswirkungen auch auf
entwicklung kleiner kinder weil also
monate lang jetzt reden wir gar nicht
vom atmen ja also mein sohn geht eine
ganztagsschule das heißt er hat für
morgen 8 uhr das schulgebäude betreten
hat bis um 15 uhr 20 wo ich ihn abgeholt
habe durchgängig maske getragen außer
beim essen sondern einfach in der
entwicklung eines kindes wenn es
gesichtsmimik nicht wahrnehmen kann das
führt zunächst zu schwierigkeiten beim
lernen
weil zb bei fremdsprachen und andere
mehr ich die die lippenbewegungen nicht
sehen kann aber wir diese erst sinn
erklärte gerade bei kindern sagen wir
mal und das ist ja dieses also mein kind
nur so dass in der ersten das ist jetzt
genau die zeit zwischen dem fünften und
siebten achten lebensjahr wo sich so
etwas wie ein soziales verständnis
herstellt das muss ich lernen und das
findet ganz viel übermütig und mimik und
gestik statt und wenn ich das gar nicht
in der schule einüben kann dann dass
bestimmte kinder die das wahnsinnig in
ihrer entwicklung zurück wirft also ist
es viel mehr als nur atmend gründler
nicht frei atmen können so und das finde
ich das für mich immer auch
deprimierende gewesen der letzten zwei
jahre man sieht eben
leben an wen die regierung damals zuerst
denkt er nicht in die kinder stark wie
zuletzt ja und die kinder standen leider
ganz ganz weit unten ich muss sagen mir
war die maske insofern immer lange zeit
recht weil ich nach der hauptsache sie
machen die schulen nicht mehr zu also
die kinder rein bevor wieder alles ja
schlimmer geht's immer deswegen habe ich
auch quasi eben gerade so angefangen
wenn man immer denkt das geht nicht
immer es geht eben doch schlimmer und
bevor man das quasi wieder macht das ist
auch meine große sorge dass wir
irgendwann wieder in die situation
kommen wenn man sagt nein und das war
dann doch alles schwere und die maske
abgeschafft also genau das szenario was
sie eben gerade auch mit der in fliegt
aufgezeichnet haben da habe ich jetzt
sorge mit der masken pflicht und ich
glaube dass wir jetzt zu einem punkt
gekommen sind und damit spielt auch die
situation in der wir jetzt sind eine
große rolle dass man sagt es wird
irgendwie so weitergehen dieses corona
thema wird uns weiter begleiten
vermutlich über jahre lang konnte mir
denken aber dann müssen wir doch an den
punkt kommen wo wir etwas ändern denn
wenn wir so weitermachen ich habe eine
dreijährige zwillinge wie die einkaufen
gehen spielen dann setzen sie sich eine
maske auf weil die andere sind nicht ins
spielzimmer einlässt wenn sie einkaufen
spielen und da waren punkto irgendwie
müssen wir schauen dass wir uns als
menschen auch wieder finden also fleisch
das anekdotische habe ich auch mal ganz
kurz machen mein sohn geht in die kita
seit letzten sommer und er hat alle
krankheiten gehabt die man sich
vorstellen kann auch jetzt gerade außer
corona und ich fast wir hatten so eine
angst wir haben wir haben die
schulkinder gesehen die maske getragen
haben wie kann unser kind das auch nur
überleben ohne maske und immer wieder
infizieren sich kinder in seiner gruppe
und seiner aktie auch alle und für uns
was schon wieder ein mysterium also es
hat sich nicht verbreitet wie man denkt
wenn einer hat dann hat er mit dem album
gehört auch das ging immer hin und her
hat meiner gehabt hat mein mann nicht
gehabt wir haben zumindest keinen
eindeutigen zusammenhang gesehen und wir
haben auch viele freunde die kinder
haben und die sechs sieben acht jahre
und so weiter ich musste alle maske
aufsetzen da haben sie einen gekriegt
andere nicht gekriegt ein mann zu lassen
hat sich verbreitet ein anderer klassen
hat sich nicht verbreitet was ich sagen
möchte ist der eindeutige zusammenhang
zwischen kinder mit einer maske schützen
sich eher von corona gegenseitig von der
inspektion als kinder ohne maske den
sehe ich bis heute nicht und den zu
unserem glück jahr dreimal auf holz
geklopft hat es bisher ist es bisher
nicht so weit gekommen ich frage mich
nur immer wenn man doch bei 45 jährigen
kindern das gesehen hat dass es eben
sich nicht ja wir halt verbreitet wie so
war es dann bei 67 jährigen kindern
überhaupt nicht möglich auch nur zu
überlegen ob man vielleicht gerade
dieser so wichtigen phase auch für die
kinder entwicklungsphase
probeweise vielleicht auch darauf zu
verzichten